[Music]
shelli's right in support of
acknowledged legislators everywhere yes
Percy we appreciate that we understand
that we know they publish that after you
die but we we got the memo by policy
wasn't on my versa fires it wasn't on my
folk who write words on the page she was
talking about all human beings who must
your imagination and empathy to conceive
of an alternative reality given the
nightmarish catastrophic driven
realities most of us have to come to
terms with which means to live a life of
a certain kind is to be a poet an artist
of life and artists of living one who
through one's deeds and actions and
witness exemplifies and imagination and
an empathy that is subversive in terms
of relating to the past which it has 42
and courageous in the present to pass on
to the next generation some wind at
their back if you want to know what hope
is just zoom in on August 1955 with
Emmett Till's mother when she's asked to
speak before not just public but the
whole world because the cameras were
there from all the various nations and
there's her baby in the coffin with the
coffin open they tried to make sure they
kept the coffin closed you said no they
gonna keep it open we just fetched his
body from the Tallahatchie River in Jim
Crow gutbucket Mississippi killed by
cowardly hateful American terrorists
white supremacist we gonna keep it open
this is my only baby what you got to say
Mamie teal to the world I'm not speaking
on behalf of myself she says I'm not
speaking to have a black people or
America I'm speaking on behalf of the
best of the human species it is what I
don't have a minute that hate our
pursuit justice for the rest of my life
as being a hope it's an echo that
magnificent moment in Reinhold libros
1932 classic more men and
all society Ryan Hall says any justice
has only just as soon degenerates into
something less than justice justice must
be rescued by something grander and
deeper than just as mainly love love
justice not identical but indivisible
but Martin says justice of what love
looks like in public he's talking about
it in the legacy of Jerusalem not the
legacy of Athens
so for Plato justice is a norm to giving
and having one's do but in Amos justice
is a force it's a major force it's an
answer to the question that Walter
Hawkins and his song what is this how do
I count for this fire I have inside a
meet that will give me any peace I've
got to somehow get it out and if I don't
do something the rocks are gonna cry out
that's as substantial I wouldn't even
call it spiritual because we know
religious folk have no monopoly on it
given the history of religious
institutions accommodating themselves to
the most vicious forms of bestiality and
atrocity be against our Jewish brothers
and sisters in the history of
Christianity
it could be against Muslims it could be
against everything because women
engaging layers of black book whatever
thank God for the history of the
heretics and the blasphemers
that's my craft look at the history of
communism my god every self-conscious
Marxist finds him or herself usually
having to leave the Communist Party in
order to be true to the best to call
mark
why because of the ossification of the
petrification of institutions in that
way hope is as sustainable keep coming
back to that point
in the issue of integrity that the boys
raise is quintessential of course we
live in an age of what cupidity love of
money I didn't say stupidity that's too
easy even though that's part of the
problem but it's cupidity because
wouldn't be a donald trump with
wonderful Wall Street corporate he leads
the Republican Party that was so
complicitous and willing to adjust
themselves to it or even a democratic
party there's two milquetoast and acts
like they want to be part of resistance
but usually have to be brought in
kicking and screaming because the demos
wake up and just hit the streets the way
the sisters did the day after the
inauguration night hit hit the airports
the way our precious brothers and
sisters in solidarity with and following
so-called undocumented brothers and
sisters you see oh those are the ones
we've been in the vanguard those are the
poets the artists the vanguard of the
species integrity over against cupidity
and venality and the saddest feature of
our present moment and that's why you
always so visionary because you all came
up with this doing age of Obama
I see for a lot of people they didn't
need to talk about hope on the Obama
because Obama is already providing the
hope of course I didn't get that memo
but that's another lecture that's
another lecture we're not gonna get into
that good night
no no I'm suspicious of anybody tied to
Wall Street military-industrial complex
assassinating American citizens without
accountability I'm critical of anybody
anybody the top one percent get ninety
five percent of the income growth and
ninety four percent of the jobs that you
brag about a short-term contemporary
temporary precarious jobs and somehow
you're going to talk about the low
unemployment rate why don't you just
take a look at these precious foking
these communities dealing with these two
or three jobs trying to put it all
together
start with the university with adjunct
professors
don't brag to me about how wonderful the
status quo is and therefore audacity of
hope' but that's another lecture my
point is this my point is this that
everybody is for sale everything is for
sale your glucose was right
pervasive ubiquitous commodification
tied to militarization in our relations
with one another in relation to police
and local citizens relation of CIA and
State Department in Pentagon to Yemen
and Pakistan and Afghanistan in relation
to undermining democratic regimes in
Honduras in relation to Libya in
relation to the West Bank under Israeli
occupation in relations of poor Jewish
folk inside of Israel given the
increasing wealth inequality within
Israel itself commodification
militarization and then of course Niger
is Asia what is nigger is Asian the
attempt to make sure that those Sly
Stone call everyday people are so scared
and intimidated and afraid and feeling
so hopeless and helpless that they'll
never straighten their backs up walk
around feeling is if they can't make a
difference the voices don't matter you
can hear brother Martin Luther King
saying from the grave
any time ordinary people straighten that
backs up they're going somewhere cuz
folk ain't ride your back unless it's
been and as an echo of Thoreau and world
and when he talks about the sleepwalkers
and as they sleep the focal walking on
their backs and the wind they wake up
and stay woke and not just stay woke the
way our precious young folk talk about
the black lives matter but stay four to
five as you
we'll walk then the folk who are walking
on your back find themselves in
precarious situations
that's called revolution revolution mine
revolution in values revolution and
priority is a transformation of self and
community and society and there is no
transformation without a positive
transformation without this dialect are
going to play of love as a form of death
from which hope emerges in the form of
action
[Music]